[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you were telling me about epstein and
this island
years ago you were telling me long
before anybody would i think you told me
about him before his first arrest
a long time ago i talked about how they
have these islands they fly they
compromise children but i learned all
this from ted gunderson
20-plus years ago he was in line to be
the fbi director he was the head of the
fbi in los angeles he was a very famous
fb uh agent even ranco intel pro
he came out and he was the one that
explained to me about how they use these
these blackmail rings elements the cia
uh and foreign intelligence groups and
and how they would ambitiously make
people have sex with children to be part
of these clubs and these cults they were
setting up so i knew about all this from
ted gunderson you know how deep epstein
is oh my god no it has that and look at
that the chick has disappeared dude not
only did he not was the chick uh no one
knows nobody thought no one cares why
you know why
why doesn't the media care
you don't think there's some kind of
connection there
why wouldn't the media be all over just
lane maxwell think about that why
wouldn't the media call for her to get
arrested you think why hasn't she been
brought in for questioning her father
her father's robert maxwell he
uh jeff epstein took over for him he you
look into that [ __ ] robert
maxwell that guy was a huge in his job
was he worked for all the intelligence
agencies the main one he worked in uh
for
israeli intelligence
they ended up killing him allegedly but
while he was alive his job was to
blackmail politicians
ceos scientists celebrities sports
athletes
as many different powerful people as you
can like if you're if your job is to
blackmail people like
you would definitely like ask uh who are
the most important people to blackmail
like where blackboard is just
blackmailing random people just picking
people out of the mall and just we're
gonna blackmail you no specific people
with power
who's who's uh when you're on that side
of when you're on the dark side
uh a good person to
blackmail would be a politician for sure
right no one's gonna disagree with that
uh celebrities for sure
um anybody with power with influence for
sure
um
uh also scientists he was blackmailing
scientists why would you blackmail
scientists what what would be the
purpose there
if you had to guess to shut them up
about something to say whatever they
need them to say about this uh
scientific experiment or that scientific
experiment or these tests or those tests
for these drugs or for whatever
blackmailing scientists is huge
massive galen it's gizlane gizlane
that's a ridiculous name yeah her father
was a famous uh mi6 massage spy that
reportedly used sex operatives to
control people he died being thrown off
a yacht
in the middle of the atlantic ocean
and of course she uh got caught in that
farmhouse on the east coast and she was
really the pimp over epstein in a giant
sex network ring over scientists that
they were compromising uh so they could
control not just government but industry
and science and so that was the master
blackmail operation they were running
and her sisters are big in tech
like isabel maxwell she has sisters that
are in u.s tech companies i think two of
her sisters uh were part of the creation
of magellan which was that big search
engine like really so yeah they are a
very powerful family and they have all
kinds of different operations yeah her
dad was the biggest publisher in england
and also the biggest owner of private tv
stations in england
and uh when he died it turned out he was
a front basically for intelligence
networks that guy that they put to sell
that lunatic
uh who's that big muscled guy i think he
was just he did it for money kept his
mouth shut that's money from whom do you
think
mossad mi6 cia all three
so there's a lot of pressure from a lot
of different profits probably probably
mossad cia more
i mean it seems very clear that he was
working inside of a honeypot
intelligence operation just lane
maxwell's father was an israeli super
spy uh just lane maxwell's working for
israeli intelligence it would be odd to
think and of course the cia knows about
everything that israeli intelligence is
doing with americans
so i would think that it's a very cozy
relationship with those two intelligence
agencies and uh i think if you ran it by
anyone i think if you ran up by french
intelligence they'd go yeah no get get
him i don't think there's any
intelligence service in the world whose
job is to protect the powerful people
that live in their countries that was
against him getting whacked
but do you think it's possible that he
is just an evil person who is after
manipulating people and also
so that there's a big earth thing
factual that there's a bigger thing evil
people don't get hurt those are your
facts tim dillon no there's the facts of
the case you don't get handed a 65. show
me another evil guy who was handed a 65
million dollar
uh place by les wexner show me another
evil guy that got that type of uh
handshake deal where he was basically uh
let off without anything after a judge
had made a very
sweetheart deal for him after he was
accused of you know molesting a 14 year
old show me another evil guy that uh
doesn't have that kind of backing that
has those type of friends those
connections those type of properties
show me uh you know multiple passports
all over the world so show me a guy
without anyone backing him that's doing
it why did they you know so you think
he's just an evil guy who's doing this
for whom it's his own just shits and
giggles you know what's crazy about the
epstein thing yep they whoever they is
were right they were sitting back and
they were going yeah they're gonna care
about it they're going to make shirts
that say epstein didn't kill himself
they're going to have some like fodder
and act they're actually going to have
more fun with the fodder
than actually they care about getting a
result then they care about justice yeah
then they care about justice just
knowing what happened they just want
something to bicker about that's what we
are like that's what the mask thing is
right now that's what the vaccine thing
is like you just need uh things to
distract you right like you just need
something there's need to be something
we cry about we have to be polarized it
has to be teams and there always has to
be some discussion and it was everybody
hates trump and now there's not a figure
that everybody really hates like people
don't like
love biden or hate biden he's just kind
of like there and we don't have enough
access to him he doesn't say enough
things for us to be pissed off him so
there needs to be another thing the mask
the vaccine whatever but with the epson
thing they were [ __ ] right they're
like they're gonna bicker about it but
life is too good for them to actually do
something and then they'll just move on
my favorite conspiracy theory joke world
having 52 000 subs here on youtube but
only 6 500 followers on instagram go
check out the instagram guys we're
featuring a new up-and-coming comedian
every single day if you like them you
can throw them some likes if you don't
like them you can have some fun talk
some [ __ ] in the comments it's up to you
listen we've built this community of
like-minded comedy fans here on youtube
and even if we took half of that over to
instagram we could build a really cool
thing where it's an honor to be featured
on that joke world instagram and the
best part is we're saying everyone who
follows and dms free stickers free joke
world stickers we got these logo ones we
just got some airplane peanut stickers
in a lot of exciting stuff going on
instagram go check it out right now link
in bio
are frogs gay
you want to get to the frog stuff now
connect it all this assassin was super
weird um the judge it was assigned to
look into the money laundering at
deutsche bank so a bunch of investors at
george bank were like hey why are you
letting jeffrey epstein and all these
people why are you tolerating all these
high-risk clients right so a bunch of
investors at deutsche bank got mad at
this and douchebag should have just sent
out a letter when shut the [ __ ] up right
we do what we want we're criminals dummy
what do you think goes on here we
launder drug money and everything else
we got narco traffickers human
traffickers shut the [ __ ] up you didn't
care when you were returned you only
care because it's the goddamn news cliff
they should like if you like like hit
him with a first name first name you
know listen vance you know what's going
on shut the [ __ ] up
um
so
but so there were some banks so there's
some investors i don't know all about it
so there's some investors yeah and
they were all working with the same a
lot of shady people work from the same
bank yeah deutsche bank okay and they're
deutsche bank's like a lot of their
executives end up killing themselves in
malibu it's super suspect because people
in malibu don't kill themselves they're
happy right they kill themselves right
so this idea that all these people in
malibu were like i just can't do another
day in the sun i gotta kill myself
deutsche bank's involved in some weird
stuff so
deutsche bank and what is the deutsch
it's what
german okay yeah so they uh are handling
high-risk clients like jeffrey epstein
okay and a bunch of investors like hey
why are you what are you doing here why
are you tolerating this level of risk
blah blah blah so they bring a class
action suit against twitch bank a judge
gets assigned that suit four days later
her son and her husband a guy shows up
in a fedex suit her son and her husband
end up getting killed or her husband's
not dead he's critically wounded her son
is dead and then the guy who does this
goes and kills himself about an hour and
a half later now supposedly this guy
this guy named roy hollander was a men's
rights activist who had actually called
an opium anthony and like argued with
jim norton it's like a weird guy and he
was the fedex driver he was just yeah
dressed up in a fedex outfit he was fake
fedex was a regular vehicle i imagine
yeah oh my god so then he just didn't
give away himself so what people are
what i am a little suspicious about is
i'm like is this guy actually the guy
who did it
is this guy did he do it but did
somebody like put him up to it right
because this you know this is a crazy
coincidence that
this woman's child is now dead because
that is a crazy way to send a message
right like because you're telling all
the old judges like hey you might want
to gamble with your life we'll kill your
kids right like we'll just kill everyone
you know like it is a crazy message um
and it makes you think about anytime
somebody kills themselves they can't be
asked any questions i get real like wait
a minute hold on what happened so
it's entirely possible that this was
some type of threat
or
you know a way to intimidate or scare
people that are in the case i don't know
it's also possible that this guy's just
a crazy guy that killed the judge i
don't know but it's worth looking into
half these people on twitter that are
like all right your humanity they
haven't seen their brother in five years
yeah be good to the people you can be
you want to force political change do it
i'm proud of you that's not what i do i
make people laugh
good for you
if you feel that you can do it go do it
great edward snowden thought he could do
it he's in moscow now
[Laughter]
michael hastings wanted to do it his car
emoliated right outside of australia
mocha on larchmont kennedy wanted to do
it martin luther king wanted you see
what i'm getting at
you see where i'm going here
obama thought he wanted to do it and
then he goes i'll just go on ellen and
dance
went great great
bombs away
and he'll just dance none of these
[ __ ] care this is why people get
banned
from the internet this this these kind
of conversations we better ban it right
now let's not ban it i'm just not i'll
throw that out look at this thing that
we all just watched in front of our eyes
we saw a guy going to jail
try to they tried to suicide them a week
jeffrey epstein they put him in another
prison stand and then they moved them
i watched the 60 minutes i read the
thing
and it's just
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah like i've been in
jail
do you understand me that i've been in
jail i've been in county
i've been in county i've been in [ __ ]
state i was a member when you got
arrested for kidnapping kidnapping is
automatically a federal offense yeah so
they put you in federal holding i've
been in every
pen through the [ __ ] system
the only way you hang yourself
is when somebody kills you yeah you know
what i'm saying yeah people hang
themselves they do they really do but in
today's society with the technology you
got
now think about it you're gonna tell me
there wasn't one guard with a screen
joey diaz has a screen here
i don't have no money cameras didn't
work when that happened yeah
think about it and think about the media
they're leaving it alone okay so right
cameras didn't work cameras didn't work
but they're still rounds
yeah they're still rounds
well he got pulled out of suicide watch
that night why
it's 72 [ __ ] out you know it's stuff
that a guy like me
really knows and i go really
really you're going to tell me some guy
[ __ ] iced himself who's the head
lizard now do you know who it is
is joe biden lizard
somebody told me he was lizard he'd like
to be a lizard he can't make it biden
can't make it as a lizard he's like he's
kind of a lizard yeah
but not fully you know no it's always
here's the thing with there is no head
lizard person
they all shift and that's the thing with
people what people don't understand
about conspiracies they think it's one
group or they think it's five guys in a
room with cigars
it's actually this was a guy that said
this on my show it's just society
at the highest levels perpetuating
itself
that's all it is
it's not
neat
and it's not clean it's people that will
go to war with each other
immediately but when they're faced with
a common enemy they'll band together
because they have that solidarity
um it's people
that are in big business government
media
all over the place wherever they are
hollywood they're just about they're at
the apex of society and they'll do
anything to stay there
any anything they'll arrange the game in
any way that it is favorable to them and
their the ways of doing that would blow
people's minds the ways that people
maneuver the ways that they can exert
control on other people would fascinate
people yeah that i think is what's truly
fascinating when you look at these
[ __ ] senators and congressmen that
all show up to washington dc
and almost immediately they start voting
against the interests of their home
districts right the people that they've
grown up with their whole [ __ ] lives
sorry ma
you're not getting that [ __ ] implant
shut up you go how did this happen and
then you realize
oh the pressures that are on them are
coming from all these different places a
lot of those people are having
extramarital affairs some of them have
drug problems some of them have cheated
on their taxes some of them are in a
much worse sicker things
and there are ways that people can hold
them
in a place and make them do what they
want and and and make sure that they are
useful and they come i mean that's what
this has been going on for a very very
long time you compromise people and you
put them in the position of doing what
you want some people don't even have to
be compromised because they just do it
[ __ ] anyway yeah because they're just
standing for the buy but that's i think
the difference i don't think people
realize how widespread that is
and how effective people are
at
getting people to do what they want
before you any further you said att has
it been proven that it's a t or are you
just saying 18th like companies like
let's just say i'm not saying atg is bad
i think att's overall good company but
is att doing something bad
no i just i was mentioning that as a
fortune 500 company okay but it's not
18t no it's not 18 so we shouldn't say
that see this is why you need someone
that's like a fact checker right now no
no slow down the media will say i'm
wrong right about that but okay okay but
no no hold on his personal lawyer
his personal lawyer the one that ended
up going to jail
actually michael cohen michael cohen was
getting money from att go ahead and pull
it up i mean i was just trying to give
you a gestalt question
but i just want to i've told you before
what you really need on your show is
like a legit journalist who's right next
to you with a laptop going ah alex hold
on hold on just slow down but i think
you're right about that because you get
so much right but when you get something
wrong that's what you gotta understand
is att confirms it paid trump lawyer
michael cohen's company yeah now i
remember that see joe
they're always saying that i'm making
stuff like they're lying right right
yeah every once in a while my memory
used to be photographic but from
everything i've done it's not as good as
it used to be it moves really quick okay
so what i'm saying stuff is just
data knowledge okay and then i can like
okay yeah did i say that yeah it's real
check it out but i'm not trying to make
stuff up 99 of the time here it is att
confirmed tuesday evening that paid
president trump's personal loyal michael
cohen in 2017 for in quotes insights
into understanding the new
administration
insights i love that um so how much they
pay him 200 000 bucks and four separate
payments of 50 bucks in late 2017 early
2018. interesting yeah but he got paid i
think the number was 10 million total
from a handful of companies
did it shady look avenatti alleged that
essential consultants a shell company
set up by cohen before the election to
pay stormy daniels was paid by several
corporations including a t at the time
att was seeking government approval for
its acquisition of time warner cnn's
parent company
it's a dirty world yeah but i'm telling
you at t is a sweetheart compared to
google and facebook and twitter and all
these people now
they just there's enough dirt on
everybody to force people out with
scandals the elliot spitzers people like
that you could kind of if you anger the
wrong people that could kind of just get
rid of you so i i think that a lot of
these conversations we have is like it
left right it's kind of like these are
false choices yes they are because the
reality is
we're in a hell of a mess
and we're not getting out that's what i
come to tell everyone sure we're not
getting out it doesn't get better no
your thoughts have no value it doesn't
matter what you believe or what you say
or
none of that matters we're we're past
the peak of this empire it will
disintegrate
it will maybe slowly like this hopefully
yeah but i mean you know there's never
been an empire that had the military
strength that we do in the financial
position we're in which is 20 trillion
in the hole but we still have the give
or take strongest military so that is
interesting because that you go well at
that point do you do you go
was is a war needed something's needed
uh but i don't know what'll happen but i
i'm one of these people the problem with
politics is you go out to lunch with
people and they go if we just did this
it would be okay
and you go you know i don't think so
you know i don't think so yeah i have
right here in my notes
the carbon conspiracy and that is
specifically
what i wanted to get into here
with you in my notes because this is
everything are you a climate change
denier well see imagine imagine how
that's how they use that term right are
you a climate change denier it's like a
911 denier right no the towers got blown
up our government had prior warning and
have been funding al-qaeda and all that
came out later in senate reports and the
28 points let's not go there just now
because we're going to go down a route
that that's true but let's go to carbon
that agree with you there okay what are
you what is what is what is what is joe
rogan made up out of carbon okay-based
life-forms we are literally stardust
what our song right exactly what are
trees made out of
um
tree stuff i didn't vote i just don't
vote i live in new york i don't care i
voted for george w bush once obama wants
the next top vote and once nothing ever
changed obama wants him but not obama
too no because nothing changed obama
then
you you got to get to a certain point
when you realize nothing changes yeah
nothing real other than like the social
things
that you know gay marriage will happen
and this will happen and that'll happen
and i'm not saying to totally disengage
but the foreign policy economic policy
things like that it's not huge like
we're just gonna do a lot of what you
know obama came in it was like the
american military we cannot do things
and then we're we're at war for seven
years drone striking every
secret prison cia kidnapping it's all
the same [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it doesn't matter it really doesn't
matter is trump gonna win again you
think it matters because then they
matter yeah because if that matters well
i don't know you gotta win my vote right
i don't know who i'm voting for shut up
you shut up eat the cake shake die
eat the cake shake it down [ __ ] have
a say you don't have to say
imagine you had a say
in schaumburg illinois
eating a [ __ ] heart attack imagine
someone came to you and said what do you
think the trade policy would be you
don't have this you've never had a say
but nobody likes that right nobody likes
that it's hard to admit people want to
have you you don't have to say you think
you do
because you vote it's fun you go this
team and my team and you and me
yeah they don't give they start their
bomb why did we go into libya they would
explain that
we fund saudi arabia they're doing a
genocide in yemen
they don't ask they don't go uh hello
okay and they don't shut down a denny's
for five minutes ago uh everyone along
with your checks we are gonna hand out a
slip of paper are you pro or against the
genocide in yemen that we're currently
funding
yes check no x thank you we're
tabulating balance we're going to decide
no one cares
look into the corruption the bidens are
doing in ukraine look at these scams
they're running these tax scams you know
look into that [ __ ] and so that's what
the impeachment is about impeachment is
about trump is trying to dig up dirt on
his political rival because he's running
for president joe biden look let's
impeachment for trying to dig up dirt
meanwhile
biden is on video sitting at the cfr the
council on foreign relations sitting
there bragging
bragging that he got a prosecutor fired
from the ukraine he was going after his
son's company in ukraine so uh joe biden
but put his his son hunter biden on the
board of barisma an energy company
corrupt ass energy company that
a prosecutor was looking into and
seizing assets and stuff so they were uh
to to joe because joe biden was assigned
to ukraine like that was his [ __ ] he was
a vice president and obama put him in
charge of ukraine
so
barisma's going dude get this [ __ ]
prosecutor up my [ __ ] ass right so
biden said okay of course because his
son's on the goddamn board of course
he's going to get that so he's at the
cfr you can watch us on youtube you
could watch there's all the he's
bragging and um he says
he's he's telling all these illuminati
guys saying hey listen i told the guy i
said listen you better fire that
prosecutor and listen i'm listen leaving
in six hours were you living we were
living in like six hours right yeah six
hours i told michael you're not gonna
get your billion dollars in aid unless
you fire the prosecutor and then he said
you know what he said he goes you don't
have the authority you're not the
president goes you know what i said call
barack see what happens and everyone's
laughing all these old [ __ ] are
laughing
council on foreign relations that's
rockefeller [ __ ] and he's bragging in
front of all these people these old
people who actually make all the laws
and now he goes and guess what boom he
was fired and they're all laughing
so it's on video
he was holding back a billion dollars do
you know what they do is they get a
billion dollars in aid let's we got to
help ukraine they're getting tortured to
send them a billion and everybody
they're tugging at everyone's hearts yes
it's i let's sign this bill send them a
billion no one's getting no [ __ ] aid
when we send a billion dollars of aid to
countries no one's got no money it's all
going in people's pockets you know what
they do they they
let's say maybe half of it goes to
whatever corrupt politicians in the
ukraine are getting it and the other
half the deal is
a donate to our foundations and that's
how they they
launder it through their foundations as
donations i got my fridge's lane shirt
because i believe all women
[Music]
you